a lot of energy all right you can now
finally tune turn back the hands of time
at the back to the 80s cafe it's on
maryland parkway and tropicana near unlv
as you can imagine everything from the
decor to the music and the food is all
inspired by the 80s
so the food everything from you know we
have a monte cristo
everything is catered to the 80s we have
a dark brown burger we have the under
the giant burger which
stands about that high and is about that
big and it's massive and so
you know that comes with either fries or
surprise or tetris tots are
our tater tots are actually in the shape
of uh tetris so
you know you're actually welcome to play
with your food this is awesome
the back to the 80s cafe is open from 11
a.m to 9 p.m
tuesday through thursday and until 10
p.m on fridays and saturday jc really
quick favorite 80s movie
back to the future oh that's a good one
yours weird science
science sciences oh it's a classic i
know all right all right let's take
things